et une page sport maintenant avec le
vetathlon des policiers d'élencour qui
aura lieu ce jeudi 27 juin pour en
parler avec nous Stéphane detco bonsoir
vous êtes major de police dis parce que
vous êtes venus en uniforme voilà vous
êtes organisateur donc du vetathlon
alors d'abord un vetathlon de quoi
s'agit-il et bien écoutez c'est une
course qui associe le VTT et la course à
pied donc les coureurs vont s'exercer
ensemble euh donc d'abord 3 km de course
à pied autour d'un bassin un plan d'eau
puis ils vont prendre leur VTT pour
aller faire 18 km en forêt donc dans un
lieu assez escarpé puis ensuite ils vont
reposer les VTT pour aller refaire
encore 2 km 6 de course à pied et tout
ça sur quel secteur ça part du du bassin
de la Courance alors tout à fait ça part
du bassin de la Courance donc au niveau
du plan d'eau de la Courance puis après
ils vont en forêt sur un petit plateau
assez scarpé avec des belles petites
montées puis donc ils finiront donc donc
l'enchaînement de la la course à pied
encore autour du bassin de la courence
alors ce qui est un peu étonnant c'est
un peu aussi le type de personne engagé
parce que il y a des policiers des
gendarmes tout à fait donc bah écoutez
l'idée de départ c'était il y a environ
9 ans donc avec un ancien major qui est
à la retraite aujourd'hui qui viendra
courir le VTT donc il vient des Deux
Sèvres donc dans un vaisstière on a mis
en place on a dit bah pourquoi pas faire
quelque chose un échange entre les
policiers des uniformes les les
militaires les pompiers les polici
micipal et aussi là depuis 2 ans on a
ouvert aussi le vathlon civil l'idée est
démarrer comme ça et puis petit à petit
on a mis en place donc moi je suis
président de l'ambicade des policiers en
cours donc ça a aussi favorisé le fait
de mettre en place la logistique et vous
avez dit il y a il y a un concurrent qui
va venir des Deux Sèvres ça veut dire
qu'on vient pas que des ivel alors
attendez vous vous avez des gens qui
viennent de chartre vous avez des gens
qui viennent de fécand oua donc il
viennent de loin du 77 de Bron dans 69
ça dire quoi ça veut dire que ce genre
d'initiative c'est assez rare de
rassembler d'abord plusieurs corps cor
je sais pas écoutez je pense qu'il y a
des courses cyclistes donc j'ai un ami
pompier monsieur frabre qui organise la
revancharde par exemple he on est proche
et c'est vrai Queau sein des uniformes
c'est une course qui a lieu dans le 78
he il y en a pas énormément notamment
autour d'un d'un lieu comme la forêt et
cetera puisque c'est pas sur la route
par contre c'est vrai que c'est un
esprit plutôt convivial de partage de
d'échange et puis de se mesurer aussi
aux uniformes au policiers engagés bon
il y ap qu'est-ce qui avait gagné
l'année dernière c'est un poli alors
alors écoutez je suis content parce que
c'était un ancien policier d'élancour
qui est parti en bac départementale et
qui a c'est pas la garde des polices
alors du tout au contraire c'est
vraiment un moment d'échange de de de gu
vous avez dit depuis 2 ans c'est ouvert
au au civil on peut dire ça comme ça
j'ai pas on l'a ouvert au civil depuis 2
ans parce que c'est vrai qu'on on est
parti d'un principe que forcément ben
force de constater qu'on a de moins en
moins de monde qui peut être détaché
puisque c'est un moment de détachement
pendant la semaine et aussi on s'est dit
ben pourquoi beaucoup de civil venez
nous voir mais pourquoi on pourrait pas
participer B oui bien sûr bien sûr au
contraire euh redonne aussi un petit peu
une image un peu oui et oui c'est ce que
j'allais vous demander est-ce que ça
peut faire changer l'image de la police
alors changer l'image je suis pas bien
placé pour pour en parler parce que bon
il y a il y a mes instances
hiérarchiques qui répondront mieux que
moi mais si vous voulez c'est vrai que
on essaie aussi de montrer une image
positive de la police au travers des
courses cyclistes et vous savez il y a
toujours un moment après autour d'un
barbecue qui permet aussi d'échanger et
de poser des questions et puis de se
mesurer donc c'est vrai que les civils
apprécient fortement vous allez n nous
raconter un petit peu justement cet
échange autour du barbecue dans quelques
instants mais je vous propose d'abord
d'écouter cette cette question du jour
est-ce que le sport peut permettre de
réunir policiers et citoyens c'est
justement notre question du jour on
écoute les répond je pense que oui
mais ça ça reste encore à voir faire du
vélo avec des policiers ça ne me
dérangerait pas non bien sûr faut voir
faut voir pourquoi pas ça dépend quelle
activité sportive je pense qu'il
faudrait euh effectivement avoir des
liens plus étroits une petite balade ça
peut là on peut renforcer effectivement
des liens on a le temps de d'échanger
pourquoi pas de toute façon toute
activité ensemble permet de créer des
liens bien sûr oui ça peut ça peut bah
se familiariser avec eux déjà pour moi
je TR oui c'est c'est c'est une bonne
idée quoi ça dépend des gens ça dépend
de du sport ça dépend de pas mal de
choses moi je moi j'apprécie mais après
c'est vrai qu'il y a d'autres personnes
quand on voit des manifestations ou
autes il y a toujours des gens qui sont
pas très euh qui sont pas très d'accord
si c'est dans le but de
fédérer la police et les jeunes pourquoi
pas c'est pas des animaux cont des
animaux c'est des êtres humains qui
jouent ensemble voilà
des êtres humains qui jouent qui sont
ensemble je pense positif ils sont ils
sont positifs les
MICR je pense que en général ça se passe
super bien et c'est vrai
que je reviens sur cet échange barbecue
donc festif les gens ont vraiment des
des vraies questions ils se posent des
vraies questions sur le soit le
fonctionnement de la police sur la façon
dont les PO peuvent intervenir dans leur
quartiers je pense qu'on est plus d'un
autre are facette où on est on va
échanger vraiment des des des choses
particulières mais c'est vraiment au
travers du sport où on va pouvoir
justement avoir des on n plus dans les
questions un petit peu où on va avoir
des répressions sur la sécurité routiè
ou autre là on est vraiment un moment de
partage des êtres humains en fait voilà
on revient un petit peu sur les
fondamentaux comme on dit chez nous
c'est vrai que même si nous on
appartient à une corporation des des
policiers vous avez aussi des pompiers
ou des gendarmes ou des militaires de
satori qui viennent et c'est vrai que
bah ils parlent aussi de leur métier de
les difficultés rencontré et puis bah
les CIV aussi le citoyen s'intéresse
exactement oui oui parce que ils sont on
est abordable on n'est pas dans une
mesure je vous êtes abordable est-ce que
vous êtes en uniforme parce que là vous
êtes venus en uniforme MAJ mais est-ce
que quand vous êtes sur le VTT ou autour
du stand d'organisation vous êtes en
uniforme on n pas en uniforme on a moi
j'ai un polo police nationale pour bien
marquer qui organise et cetera mais
souvent on est tous avec une tenue de
sport et
donc finalement bon c'est sûr que la la
la tenue pourrait para pourrait par
contre paraître un petit peu une
barrière bon là on laisse tomber un
petit peu la tenue on est plus dans dans
l'humain et et et et surtout avec une
tenue de sport est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire je rappelle que c'est jeudi
27 juin à partir de 13h alors l'horaire
est peut-être pas facile voilà il y a un
bandeau il y a un bandau qui s'est
affiché dans la 1h autour du bassin de
la vous le faites bien voil donc
toujours s'inrire hein donc il y a
toujours de la place la remise des de S
c'est à 10h et voilà donc par contre je
voulais remercier moi si vous voulez
vous me permettez juste un petit cour
instant monsieur Jean-Marie sanova qui
est directeur départemental et sécurité
publique qui grâce à lui on peut
l'organiser et puis monsieur Alexandre
Bonneville qui est mon chef de district
d'accord un allez petit dernier j'avais
promis de faire un petit coucou à Rita
qui est une collègue ADS qui vient de
réussir son concours gardien de la paix
voilà je voulais lui faire un petit
coucou ce on la salue alors
voilà la gardien de la paix sur qu' a un
concours qui qui est aussi très ouvert
le gardien de la
paix comment de de postees à pourvoir
cette année d'accord merci beaucoup
major d'être venu
sur si les gens sont intéressés
effectivement on peut venir courir et
faire du VTT jeudi après-midi autour du
bassin pas dé il aura un bon moment de
partage et en plus vous pourz parler
avec des policiers des gendarmes des
pompiers et C merci beaucoup